how many of you are tired of seeing
celebrities adopting kids from the
African continent well it's not that all
bad I was adopted I grew up in rural
Uganda lost both my parents when I was
very very young and when my parents
passed experienced all the negative
effects of poverty from homelessness
eating out of trash piles you name it
but my life changed when I got accepted
into an orphanage through one of those
sponsor and open programs I was
sponsored and given an opportunity to
acquire an education I started off in
Uganda I went through school and the way
this particular program worked you
finished high school and after high
school you go learn a trade so you
become a carpenter a mechanic or
something along those lines my case well
it was a little different they sponsor
family that was sending these twenty
five dollars a month to this orphanage
to sponsor me which never I've never met
them said well we would like to send you
to college instead oh it gets better and
they said if you get the paperwork we'll
send you to school in America instead so
with their help I went to the embassy
and apply for the visa I got the visa I
remember this day like it was yesterday
I walked out of the embassy with this
piece of paper in my hand I hope in my
step smile on my face knowing that my
life is about to change
I went home that night and I slept with
my passport because I'm afraid that
someone might steal it I couldn't fall
asleep I kept feeling it I had a better
idea for security I was like okay I'm
gonna put it in a plastic bag and take
it outside and dig a hole and put it in
there I did that went back in the house
I could not fall asleep or like oh maybe
someone saw me I went back I pulled it
out and I put it with me the entire
night or to say that it was an anxiety
filled night going to the US was just
like another speaker said was my first
time to see a plane be on one live alone
sit on it to fly to another country
December 15 2006 708 p.m. i sat in seat
7 a Fly Emirates one of the most
gorgeous beautiful women I've ever seen
walked up red little hat the white veil
I'm looking terrified have no idea what
I'm doing
she hands me this warm towel warm steamy
snow-white I'm looking at this warm
towel I don't know what to do with my
life live a lot of this damn towel
I did one of the you know anything
anyone could do in that situation look
around see what everyone else is doing I
did the same mind you I drove about
seven hours from my village to the
airport that day so I grabbed this warm
towel wipe my face just like everyone
else is doing
I look at it damn it was all dirt brown
I remember being so embarrassed that
when she came by to pick it up I didn't
give mine I still have it going to
America opened doors for me to live up
to my full god-given potential I
remember when I arrived the sponsor
family embraced me and they literally
had to teach me everything from scratch
this is a microwave that's a
refrigerator things I've never seen
before and it was also the first time I
got immersed into a new on different
culture these strangers showed me true
love these strangers showed me that I
mattered that my dreams mattered
thank
these individuals had two of their own
biological children and when I came in I
had needs they had to teach me English
teach me literally everything which
resulted in them spending a lot of time
with me and that created a little bit of
jealous with their children so if you're
a parent in this room and you have those
teenager children who don't want
anything to do with your love and
affection in fact they find it repulsive
I got a solution adopt a child we solve
her problem I went on to acquire two
engineering degrees from one of the best
institutions in the world I gotta tell
you
talent is universal but opportunities
are not and I credit this to the
individuals who embrace multiculturalism
love empathy and compassion for others
we live in a wall filled with hate
building walls brexit xenophobia here on
the African continent multiculturalism
can be an answer to many of these worst
human qualities today I challenge you to
help a young child experience
multiculturalism I guarantee you that
will enrich their life and in turn it
will enrich yours and as a bonus one of
them may even give a TED talk
we may not be able to solve the biggest
tree in the racism of this world today
but suddenly we can raise children to
create a positive inclusive connected
world full of empathy love and
compassion
Love Wins thank you
[Applause]
[Music]